all right this just [__] lasagna [__]
lasagna's just the best pastor I I
disagree with that it's just the best P
I feel like I'm being contrar on p i I
actually just don't think that's the
best pastor what's the best pastor um I
hate to say this but I think like as
I've gotten older lasagna has been
slowly going down my ranks of Pastor
tier list cuz to me it's like it's
almost don't don't say some like bougie
[__] like noi no I don't like noi that
much noi's too starchy uh I think
lasagna to me is like almost as I get
older is closer to like pizza and like
deep dish than it is to like traditional
pasta you saying that like it's a bad
thing well no I mean it's like but I
think like lasagna is far far more far
removed from pasta than I initially
envisioned it being um yeah I kind of
agree with that it was my favorite when
I was a kid yeah cuz it was like
pizza pizza they just kind of like it's
layered pizza with like no crusts which
it yeah that's why I [__] love it
this is like lasagna is basically like
without the it's improved Pizza you know
it's everything I look for I I do want
to prefer I do love lasagna but I do
actually think I prefer traditional pass
more we'll get into that later oh okay
you have it on your list all right all
right all right uh I mean this one is
kind we have to talk about chicken wings
this one is uh self-explanatory Everyone
likes chicken wings bone in or bone out
Everyone likes it how much do you like
it though do
yeah because I will say this like every
time uh chicken okay for me chicken
wings is one of those things I don't
necessarily crave but if it's on the
table I will devour it I'm I'm I'm going
[__] be honest I kind of died a
little on the tour that we did because
uh every [__] time we did not get
chicken wings once and we got chicken
tendies every every the US tour the US
tour no no no there were there were a
few times we had the when
on the bus I remember there were a few
times where we ordered [__] bone in
because you wouldn't shut the [__] up
about
it all right we'll get the [__] Boney
in for gone cuz he's bitching about this
too much yeah I I mean I can understand
this wrong I think I was close to
putting uh Wings on mine I like wings a
lot ivly I like boneless chicken a lot
and my allegiance is more closely
aligned with boneless but I do love
Wings yeah yeah I mean to me like bone
com bone in wings uh I was trying to
think if I had like a singular flavor
that I liked cuz I remember I I was like
my mom always cooked these like tide
chicken wings and I think that's where
my love of wings came from where I think
I've just I like it got to the point
where I think I ate wings at least once
a week for like for like my entire
childhood not a bad childhood at all
Japan needs to absolutely stop up they
need to stop putting hormones in the
chickens cuz this this [__] is so weak
bro it's like you get like it depends
where you go though you get quarter of a
bite on a chicken have you been to
yamachan chicken yeah but the tiny yeah
but you you get like a lot you do get a
lot [__] but it's like you literally you
like Japan uh does need to level up
their chicken game a little bit it's cuz
they don't put but I think like America
also like their wings two of these they
are stuffing their wings way too much
the reason that wings are my favorite
part of the chicken out of everything is
because to me wings have like the
perfect skin to meet ratio a lot of the
times
with that yeah like like to me the the
most important part of the Wings to me
is the flavoring of the skin cuz that's
where most of the flavoring comes from
and then the meat is kind of like the's
say yeah the the enhancer to that uh but
to me the the main star of the Wings are
uh the skin and even on like [__]
thighs you have the skin which is there
but there's like so much meat so you're
like you enjoy you enjoy the skin and
you're like [__] all right I got to I
got I got to finish this meat now you
know I I got to finish his meets um yeah
when you order like 10 wings in Japan
versus 10 wings in America one will not
fill me up at all and the other will
make me obese bu I I'll be so full yeah
so like to me to me wings has just been
like a staple of my childhood and I'm
discovering like to me I think Korean
wings are my favorite now uh that's the
I'm going through definitely me I think
Korean Fried Chicken is the best fried
chicken in the world I agree uh
just the way they fry it and the batter
and just the flavors Fried Chicken
really got the Y sauce bro
sh I I like honey honey garlic soy sauce
oh the honey garlic is good too honey
garlic is so good honey garlic soy sauce
all right so you speci specifically
salmon why okay I I I kind of had this
realization the least Japanese sushi of
all time yeah okay so I kind of had this
realization where um out of every
Japanese dish that I thought I would eat
the only anything thing I consistently
eat now um as like a comfort food that
I'm constantly craving is Sushi I don't
really go out to eat ramen uh you know I
I [__] love so many Japanese dishes
but the only one I like I view as a
comfort food probably
Sushi I don't really like high-end sushi
places because they don't normally serve
salmon and I real I realize the reason I
love going to conveyor belt Sushi is
because everything I order revolves
around salmon niggity honestly honestly
conveyor build Sushi gets too much of a
bad rep like I don't know why convey Bel
Sushi is bosson it's [__] good
actually I actually way prefer convey
Belt Sushi than high-end Sushi I mean
High sushi places do just taste
different um it's whether or not you
prefer one over the other I mean I like
like if I went to high and sushi place I
really like it but uh if I go to like
sushi doll or something I I'll [__] it I
I'll go down with the salmon and
mozzarella [__] thing they did I'm
like that's pretty fire okay it's not
sushi but it's good here's the question
how much was s did you put on it zero oh
like 100 I don't put any I hate Wasabi I
cuz like I I think the reason I prefer
conveyor belt Sushi is because I can
like just soak that [__] in I can just
soak that soy sauce in wasabi and I'm
just [__] okay okay first of all
first of all are we are we talking about
uh Wasabi when you get it like the the
fresh stuff cuz it tastes totally
different to like the horse rad you're
not going to get the fresh [__] at Sushi
no I know so we're talking about okay
we're talking about the horseradish
we're not talking about was hor radish
right yeah horse radish for me it's it's
like I don't know if it's like a genetic
thing or what but to me it's like a gas
attack on my like thing it feels like
it's just unpleasant it's not there's no
flavor part of it that I enjoy and I
really want to like it cuz like it goes
well with sushi right everyone tells you
but uh for me it's just like it's such a
harsh uh pungent like flavor that I
can't do it dude I put so much my [__]
turns green but FR but fresh Wasabi it's
like it's much more mild it's it it
tastes a lot different real Wasabi is
not even same that's something trying to
be Bouie they are just they are actually
just two different things one of them is
not Wasabi yeah I prefer the horse
radish yeah I mean that's fair like I
wouldn't I wouldn't I I that's crazy to
me but I like the horse R but I
definitely prefer real wasi it's it's
like uh you know like every time I go to
like high and sui place they always have
like the perfect kind of balance between
fish uh rice and just like the amount of
Wasabi and it's like nicely balanced
yeah I love that but sometimes I just
want to gas myself I I don't know
sometimes I just like the feeding just
and I feel I feel like a drags a little
bit like every time I have like it all
comes here I heard people call it spicy
cuz I'm like this is not [__] yeah it is
not it is shares
no it's just it's an impact to me this
is like the uh ad aqu equivalent of like
you know if if you are a person that's
uh you know you like putting a [__] ton
of Wasabi on your sushi and just being
gas that's crazy to me that you like
salmon with a [__] ton of horseradish
yeah I [__] love it's kind of like y
Cho exists and Cho with Wasabi as well
is great like Cho is way better Cho is
like I can only have one yeah what about
like normal to huh normal normal aami
like regular tuna aami is I don't know
Sal just has like that perfect balance
to me I mean it's not even my favorite I
know like to me it's like the equivalent
you know doing the Wasabi thing it's
like the equivalent of like sniffing
markers as a
kid you
know yeah I get that except hopefully
there aren't any like detrimental health
results but one makes you dumb as [__]
the other is the other one is socially
acceptable I I you know that's I think
that's kind of why I like Wasabi you
know okay it's a little wild maybe maybe
I'm a glue sniffer I don't [__]
know but yeah specifically like every
Sushi trip revolves around how much
salmon sushi can I order that seems
socially acceptable to balance out with
the with the rest of the I do think the
like I said that the sushi do this
mozzarella salmon thing it's actually
fire really you should try it I haven't
made a sush in say like on Chris's video
apparently saying it's like one of the
most popular items in the menu it's it's
not Sushi it's it's salmon rice
mozzarella and then Basel dressing that
sounds good it's actually it's so good
it's so that's like a carao dude all I
can say is carao with rice is good all I
can say is thank you Norwegians for
introducing salmon to the
Japanese singlehandedly feeding the
Japanese you've uh made the per you
you've made their dish even better in my
opinion cuz uh you don't normally get
sushi uh salmon sorry salmon sushi in
high-end sushi restaurants all right
ribs or just or just American barbecue
in general American barbecue or ribs
okay okay this is definitely going to be
hot take you got you got to pick one
okay uh definitely
ribs I think brisket is overrated yeah
brisket is overrated I'm going say too I
it's overrated explain to me what
exactly is a
brisket uh [__] that's a great question
cuz I always get confused what exactly
is a brisket what what constitutes as a
brisket um I actually don't I couldn't
tell you what a brisket is but I know I
get it I think it's a part of like the
we un yeah we are we are definitely
uneducated but cuz I don't think I had
this growing you no no this just like a
no if you've been to like an American
restaurant uh brisket is normally one of
the from the lower breast or pectral
muscles of the cow yeah so normally this
is the one that smokes the most um yeah
my my my issue and I've started having
this now with um I love American
barbecue m but the I don't know if this
because I'm getting older uh the
Reliance on needing an ungodly amount of
source is starting to turn me off uh cuz
brisket needs sauce like if if you have
it on its own it is it it is too much uh
it needs to be mellowed out with a bunch
of sauces and in America my God they're
way too sweet they load it up with the
sweetest goddamn barbecue sauce yeah if
you go to like Kansas City that's why
that's why I love Texas barbecue is
because it doesn't always rely on that
sauce there's like the dry as well which
plays into it I I will say Texas
barbecue I think is [__] goated yeah
go ribs is yeah but I I also liked
Kansas City Barbecue more which is
sweder traditionally but I like the rib
rib is my favorite part I will say rib
ribs is my favorite part but I like I
think I just like smoked meat I don't
know something about that Woody taste
that's you know I think America a
controversial opinion I think America
loves to claim they do a lot of the
things the best like fried chicken like
um pizza hot dogs they do barbecue the
best I give but I one thing I will
defend them on is their barbecues are
the best American Americans you did
barbecues right and I down that Hill you
get a platter you get like [__] mac
and cheese you get beans beans and then
you get like two you get like you get
ribs uh Burt ends are okay depends how
bur ends are great depends depends on
how much how how much sauce I can handle
yeah out of out of everything I think
brisket is my least favorite just
because it is it is a bit too much I I I
never have like ate eaten like I I
remember the first time I actually felt
like sick after eating a barbecue was
when I was in Texas and I had the
brisket it was specifically the brisket
cuz it was like so fatty and uh yeah
when it's too fatty when it's like when
it's like too fatty and this is like
it's not the same kind of fatty as like
wagu beef kind of fatty it's like a
different kind of fatty um this was like
more than like 10 McDonald's hash browns
put together kind of like oily fatty you
know yeah yeah some of them are a bit to
oily I my statement earlier where I said
like I'm getting older I don't like it I
still love it but I I find that I'm
craving it lash and lash right yeah but
I I I still like if I'm in America the
one thing I always want is American
barbecue uh one of my favorite
restaurants in Tokyo is an American
barbecue you always go there yeah
because I always crave him man I'm like
is that the one in Harajuku yeah one the
Smoke House right oh I [__] love
place is c yeah I found an American
Barbe place near my house and I go there
like place there's there's a lot of
places now I need a beer to go with it
cuz I need I need beer I have to have
beer with it getting it's getting a nice
beer with an American barbecue oh I just
T I can understand this being on the
listow I give you to much for this one
great I just my only complaint of ribs
is you either always get too much or too
little in America it's always too much
in America it's always too much in Japan
you're like really $10 for one RI are
you [__] kidding me would you would
you like a rack of two or or a rack of
TW like no in between dude I'm not
kidding a rack of ribs in Japan like a
full rack is like $60 it's insane it's
for like a for like a good like American
style done well it's ridiculous I'm just
like wondering does any other Cuisine
focus on smoked meat like I'm I'm trying
to think must be but we're probably dumb
enough I'm probably dumb and I've never
tasted it before but yeah this this just
has such an advantage to me just because
I don't know why you know specifically
smoked meat you know I know that I know
other places do like smoke cheese and
stuff like that but I
justbe there's I know there's there's
got to be other Cuisines there's got to
be other quisine out there um but for
for what I know like only I've only
experienced Americans in terms of like
really specializing and really honing in
on how to like properly smoke meat and I
[__] love it uh some of my favorite
meals is when I when I go to Wisconsin
is when you do kind of like not even
like a professional smoker but just like
a more kind of like I I know a few
professional smokers
but just having that fresh Woody fresh
Woody taste [__] love it uh smoked me
all the way for me uh yeah I can't
disagree with that it's it's great yeah
and uh to end things off
obviously I was like what uh food means
the most to me sh Ren uh I knew I had to
pick an instant Ramen because that is
what fueled me through most of my life
like you know I only just realized
looking at this 3x3 now this is like
college student with a little bit of
expendable income
diet you know I college student who can
afford food this is this is the ramen is
just everywhere um every single country
on Earth has Shin Ramen which is fine
but if you can get indomi it's way
better it's way tastier the MSG is on
God levels indom is the best I prefer
the knam Moto uhen that you get from
7-Eleven B the problem with Japan is
they don't they don't use enough MSG
they need more Ms need more MS you need
more for instant noodles you need an
ungodly amount of mg I I know I'm
betraying my own bloodline here by not
putting Mama noodles on here uh which I
was heavily considering but then I just
kind of realized that the problem with
the problem with you know my own
country's noodles is that the packaging
the packet size is never enough and I
don't know if my phow ties can like
agree with me yeah agree with but like
it's
just I agree with this this tie
statement I you your new size is a joke
you got to you got 50% it's it's it's
like one packet of Mama noodles unless
you get the extra large packet which
isn't normally on sale outside of like
Thailand but like busting out two yeah
yeah it's it's like two is too much but
one packet is way too little so you just
end up wasting yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
to like to me like to me this is like
the perfect amount of instant noodles
that also taste [__] great as well um
I didn't have this when I was growing up
uh but when I discovered this I never
looked back I have more Shin uh ramen
noodles in my house uh than I do mama I
mean I used to not be able to eat this
growing up cuz it was too spicy but now
now I [__] love it it's great it's
like the perfect amount of like spicy
which is not like like to me it's not
like an ungodly amount of spice I
sometimes have to add like a little bit
of spice to it uh of course you do but
to me it's just it's if I had this in
college
this would all this would be all I would
be eating because yeah you'd also have a
sodium overload as
well lot of other problems bro I would
happily have the sodium overload not a
bad three i' say some hits some misses
uh I I would say like going back to
going going back to the lasagna thing um
like one thing I wanted to say was I
never understood why spaghetti was
always the most like popular pasta dish
worldwide spaghetti is the worst pasta
It's it's like I think objectively
spaghetti is just the worst pasta and
one thing that kills me in every like
Italian restaurant I go to that's it's
it's always just different flavors of
spaghetti dishes that's American though
that's a very American thing is it
American yeah in Italy it's I spaghetti
is there but it's nowhere yeah spaghetti
is very selective it's like it's nowhere
near as common as some other types I'm
just wondering why did we choose why did
the world choose spaghetti as dis it's
the worst one it doesn't absorb the
[Music]
it's way too thick when you get like you
have to like [__] spin it up way too
much [__] like Pastor ratio to Sauce
It's never enough every other pasta form
like you think about like the I don't
[__] know the names P Linguini yeah
all of these ones you can get a much
better source to Pasta ratio going on uh
and it absorbs it better like it'll hold
the SCE I can't think of any like pasta
dish that normally is like you know done
with spaghetti that would not be
improved with other pastas I like an
easier e easier to make might just be
easier to make yeah yeah and cheaper to
cuz all all they have to do is pass it
through the pasta machine they to like
shape it surely like any shape would be
easier to make with I don't know how to
make dog with the right past the shaper
you know surely surely anything does it
work like a cookie cutter system or or
is this more convoluted I don't know
like the standard like uh spaghetti with
uh like what is it marinar what do they
have normally with it like the bolog
spaghet B it's so basic like I I to me
like a
an arabat with like just the penes is so
[__] good that's yeah that's like a
an easy one as well like and it's more
flavorful I think and well I think it's
also just because Bolognese is just a a
flavor that is also easy for children to
eat as well like kids can't eat [__]
AR you know and it's super easy to make
as well who says they
can't we're not all we're not all born
with high [__] taste Buzz all right
you it's not even spicy I couldn't eat
arabat you [__] [__] me no godam
dude when you were 5 years old you can't
eat a [__] arabiata yes you can yes
you can that's could kids go suck it up
he'll he'll suck it up eventually